Youth sports families and fans huddle up. Wherever life takes you, Game Changer keeps you connected. Stream games live and full HD when you can't be there. Get play-by-play updates right on your phone and share game highlights with everyone, full bragging rights included. Live the game like never before with Game Changer. Create your free account today at gc.com. Unemployment applications have hit previously unimaginable highs.
青年体育家庭和球迷们集合。无论生活带你去到哪里，Game Changer都能让你保持联系。无法亲临现场时，可观看高清比赛直播。直接在手机上获取实时战况更新，与所有人分享比赛精彩瞬间，绝对让你赚足炫耀资本。使用Game Changer，以前所未有的方式体验比赛。今天就在gc.com免费注册账号。失业申请数量创下了前所未有的新高。
The stock market is in free fall. National parks are closing and Broadway is dark, and that's just in this country. The coronavirus pandemic is global, and it's likely that we are only just beginning to see its economic impacts. So what can we do to cope? Are there strategies to help us weather this economic uncertainty? What should we be doing with our money if we still have any? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
股市正在自由落体式下跌。国家公园在关闭，百老汇在停演，而这还只是在这个国家。冠状病毒大流行是全球性的，而且我们可能才刚刚开始看到它带来的经济影响。那么我们能做些什么来应对呢？有没有什么策略能帮我们度过这种经济不确定性？如果我们手里还有钱的话，我们该怎么处理这些钱？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，
that explores how the science of psychology affects everyday life. I'm your host, Kim Mills. Even before the coronavirus struck, many of us were prone to do on wise things with our money. What, if anything, will the pandemic do to that very human tendency? How can we work against our worst financial instincts while our lives are feeling so chaotic? Our guest today, Dr. Bragg Clance, is, I hope, going to help us better understand why we do what we do with money and how we can make some better decisions even as we deal with the rocky economy ahead. Dr. Klontz is an award-winning financial psychologist and a certified financial planner.
探讨心理学科学如何影响日常生活。我是主持人金·米尔斯。甚至在冠状病毒爆发之前，我们许多人就容易对自己的钱做出不明智的事情。如果说大流行会对这种非常人性的倾向产生什么影响的话，那会是什么？当我们的生活感到如此混乱时，我们该如何对抗我们最糟糕的财务直觉？我们今天的嘉宾布拉格·克兰茨（Dr. Bragg Clance）博士，我希望他能帮助我们更好地理解为什么我们在金钱上会有那样的行为，以及即使我们在应对前方动荡的经济时，我们如何才能做出更好的决策。克兰茨博士是一位屡获殊荣的金融心理学家和认证金融规划师。
He is also an associate professor of practice in financial psychology and behavioral finance at Creighton University in Omaha, Nebraska. Dr. Kwanse, thank you for joining us. Thanks for having me. Let me start by asking the $64,000 question. Where is the economy headed? Have we hit the bottom? Yes, that's a fabulous question. And the uncertainty around that and basically not knowing that,
他还是内布拉斯加州奥马哈市克瑞顿大学金融心理学和行为金融学的客座副教授。克兰茨博士，谢谢你参加我们的节目。谢谢邀请我。我先问一个价值6.4万美元的问题。经济将走向何方？我们已经触底了吗？是的，这是一个极好的问题。围绕这一点的种种不确定性，以及基本上不知道那个，
that answer is part of what is making this such a difficult experience for so many Americans. And we don't really know. That's just the bottom line. But what we do know is that we have economic downturns like this periodically. And so we've had probably one of the longest growth periods in our economy, in our history, leading into this crisis situation in terms of the economy. And so we knew a correction was coming. I mean, we knew this was going to happen. And actually, we thought it was going to happen much earlier. And what's interesting about these corrections is you have no idea what's going to spark it off. And obviously, this time, it was the virus.
那个答案，正是让许多美国人觉得这次经历如此艰难的原因之一。而且我们真的不知道。这就是底线。但我们所知道的是，我们定期都会经历这样的经济低迷。因此，在导致这次危机情况的经济方面，我们经历的可能是我们经济史上最长的增长期之一。所以我们知道调整即将来临。我的意思是，我们知道这会发生。事实上，我们原以为它会发生得更早。有趣的是，你根本不知道是什么点燃了这些调整的导火索。显然，这一次是病毒。
And so we've been through these before. We will continue to go through these. But there's definitely a lot of uncertainty built into this experience, as there is every time an economic downturn occurs. Well, what kinds of emotions are people experiencing right now from the impact of the coronavirus? What are you hearing? Yeah. So, you know, it's the combination. So one of the things that makes this unusual is the health concerns.
所以我们以前经历过这些。我们将继续经历这些。但这次经历中确实包含了很多不确定性，就像每次经济低迷发生时一样。那么，人们目前正因冠状病毒的影响而经历着什么样的情绪呢？你都听到了什么？是的。所以，你知道，这是多种因素的结合。因此，让这次情况变得不寻常的原因之一是健康问题。
So there's very real health concerns and concern about that. My health, my children's health, my family's health. So that's part of it. And I think that actually increases our level of anxiety. And then, of course, people are really concerned about, you know, your investments if you have a retirement savings or if you're being directly impacted by the loss of a job. I mean, these have a profound impact on people. And so, you know, we're not sure, again, if we're going to be back to work in a matter of months or if it could take it longer. What about these emotional effects? I mean, how long should we expect them to last? Is this,
所以存在非常现实的健康担忧以及对此的关切。我的健康、我孩子的健康、我家人的健康。所以这是其中的一部分。我认为这实际上增加了我们的焦虑水平。然后，当然，人们真的很关心，你知道，你的投资，如果你有退休储蓄，或者如果你正受到失业的直接影响。我的意思是，这些对人们产生了深远的影响。所以，你知道，我们同样不确定我们是否能在几个月内复工，或者这可能需要更长的时间。这些情感影响呢？我的意思是，我们应该预料它们会持续多久？这会是，
we're going to have a kind of PTSD across the country and around the world? It's really interesting that you asked it in that way. Back in 2008, we did a study of financial planners during the last big recession. And yes, we actually looked at post-traumatic stress symptoms. And so, yes, there's absolutely going to be post-traumatic stress that lingers. There was a study done in Greece, too, that looked at post-traumatic stress within the entire country, absolute impact that persisted for years. And if you think back to post-traumatic stress in previous generations in these types of events, you know, I don't know about you, Kim, but my grandparents were a bit of hoarders, you know,
我们是否会在全国乃至全世界范围内经历某种创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）？你以这种方式提问真的很有趣。早在2008年，我们在上一次大衰退期间对金融规划师进行了一项研究。是的，我们实际上研究了创伤后应激症状。所以，是的，绝对会有挥之不去的创伤后应激。希腊也做过一项研究，调查了整个国家的创伤后应激情况，其绝对影响持续了多年。如果你回想一下前几代人在这类事件中的创伤后应激，你知道，金，我不知道你怎么样，但我的祖父母有点像囤积狂，你知道，
and they had gone through the Great Depression and they were significantly impacted by that. Like my grandfather lost all of his money when he went to the bank one day and all of a sudden the money's not there. This led to a shift in beliefs, anxiety around money. And this is part of my story and learning my own psychology around money. But my grandfather had lost his money. He never put a dollar in the bank the rest of his life. So he died in his 90s, never put a dollar in the bank the rest of his life. He was so traumatized by losing his money. So where was the money? Was it in his mattress? Exactly. It was in a lockbox in the attic. And he kept getting, his house kept getting broken into apparently the local criminals knew where it was. But yeah, so the lingering effect. And,
他们经历过大萧条，并深受其影响。比如我爷爷有一天去银行时失去了他所有的钱，突然之间钱就没了。这导致了信念的转变，以及对金钱的焦虑。这也是我的故事的一部分，了解我自己在金钱方面的心理。但我爷爷失去了他的钱。他在余生中再也没有把一美元存入银行。所以他九十几岁去世时，余生再也没有把一美元存入银行。他因失去金钱而受到的创伤太深了。那么钱在哪里呢？是在他的床垫里吗？完全正确。它在阁楼的一个锁盒里。而且他的房子不断地，据当地罪犯显然知道它在哪里，他的房子一直被破门而入。但是，是的，所以这种挥之不去的影响。而且，
you know, my guess is we're going to have lingering effects associated with this. Now, I will say this too. And the research around post-traumatic growth is very clear. There are all sorts of opportunities built into this too. Like there's an opportunity, perhaps you're spending more time with your family, you know, or your spouse or partner. Now, you could use this experience to grow closer. Now, some couples are actually growing further apart. So therein lies the, the crisis, but there's an opportunity for many of us to have deeper, closer connections with our family. Perhaps you're spending more time with your children as an example. Perhaps you're looking at your finances. You've been sort of avoided looking, voiding looking at it. And now all of a
我猜我们也会有与此相关的挥之不去的影响。现在，我也要说这一点。围绕创伤后成长的研究是非常明确的。其中也内置了各种各样的机会。就像有一个机会，也许你花了更多的时间和家人在一起，你知道，或者你的配偶或伴侣。现在，你可以利用这段经历来拉近距离。现在，一些情夫妇实际上正在渐行渐远。危机就在于此，但对于我们许多人来说，这是一个与家人建立更深、更紧密联系的机会。也许你花更多的时间陪你的孩子，举个例子。也许你在审视你的财务状况。你一直以来有点在逃避查看，逃避查看它。现在突然之间，
sudden you have some stress related to your finances and you want to, it's a great time to actually look at where your spending habits have been and make adjustments along the way. So lots of stress built into this. This is going to be over. It's going to be over soon. It could be a matter of months or even, let's say, a year from now, the virus situation is over. So we're going to get beyond this. And so one of the things that I've been asking people to do that I work with is to picture themselves a year from now on the other side of this virus. And looking back to yourself right now, like, how do you wish you had thought about this?
你有一些与财务相关的压力，你想，这其实是一个极好的时机来审视你的消费习惯一直在哪里，并顺便做出调整。所以这里面包含了很多压力。这一切都会过去。它很快就会过去。可能是几个月，或者甚至，比方说，一年之后，病毒疫情就结束了。所以我们会走过这一关。因此，我一直在让我与之合作的人做的一件事是，想象一下一年后的自己，身处这个病毒的另一边。回顾此时此刻的自己，就像，你希望你当时是怎么看待这一点的？
What do you wish you had done? What sort of opportunities do you wish you have capitalized on this? And this isn't to diminish the stress. This is an incredibly stressful time for many, many people on a very real level, very real psychological level, financial level. So it's not to diminish that, but there are opportunities here. So you're sounding pretty optimistic. And, you know, I'm looking at the numbers. Sixty-six million Americans just filed for unemployment. Many of these people are hourly or blue-collar workers. Their jobs may never come back. I don't understand what's going to happen to this country and maybe
你希望你当时做了什么？你希望你利用了什么样的机会？这并不是为了淡化压力。对于许许多多的人来说，这是一个非常具有压力的时期，在非常真实的层面上，非常真实的心理层面、财务层面。所以这不是为了淡化这一点，但这里确实有机遇。所以听起来你相当乐观。而且，你知道，我正在看这些数字。6600万美国人刚刚申请了失业救济。这些人中有许多是按小时计酬的工人或蓝领工人。他们的工作可能永远不会回来了。我不明白这个国家将会发生什么，也许
none of us can say right now. But what happens to the divide between the haves and the have-nots? And what are the psychological impacts as this divide widens as it may well do? Well, absolutely. And, you know, people who are economically disadvantaged going into this experience are actually going to have. I would imagine much worse sort of an experience psychologically, financially, absolutely. It is something that we're all going through together. So this is impacting people on the entire socioeconomic spectrum. So we're not alone in that sense.
我们现在谁也说不准。但是，富裕阶层和贫困阶层之间的鸿沟会发生什么变化？随着这个鸿沟的扩大（这很有可能发生），将会产生什么样的心理影响？嗯，绝对会的。而且，你知道，带着经济弱势进入这段经历的人实际上会拥有。我可以想象，在心理上、财务上都会有更糟糕的经历，绝对是的。这是我们大家共同经历的事情。所以这正在影响着整个社会经济频谱上的人们。所以从这个意义上讲，我们并不孤单。
And the virus doesn't discriminate. You know, I mean, so so you're. So your job might be a little bit more secure if you're perhaps have a white college job or not. You know, who knows? We're not really sure what's happening. A lot of people are losing jobs and experiencing a financial crisis right now. And, you know, it is, regardless of your opinions about how the government is approaching this and those very widely, and you're welcome to them, it does give us some comfort to see that our government is taking this serious and looking for ways to try to help people out with these unprecedented stimulus packages. trying to find ways to support the average American through this crisis.
而且病毒是不分长幼尊卑的。你知道，我的意思是，所以所以你。所以如果你的工作是白领工作或者不是，你的工作可能会稍微安全一点。谁知道呢？我们真的不确定正在发生什么。很多人现在都在失业并经历着财务危机。而且，你知道，无论你对政府如何处理这件事有什么看法（这些看法差异很大，而且你完全可以有自己的看法），看到我们的政府正在认真对待这件事，并寻找方法通过这些前所未有的经济刺激计划来帮助人们，这确实给我们带来了一些安慰。试图找到支持普通美国人度过这场危机的方法。
And I think that does give us a sense of some sense of security in a sense that our government is looking out for us at some level. Given what the markets are doing right now, if people haven't done anything to shelter their money, is it too late or too precarious to move to cash right now, for example? Yeah, that's a great question. And moving to cash right now is historically the absolute worst possible thing you could do. So we are wired to actually do great to survive, you know, a predator chasing us. You know, it's that fight, flight, freeze response.
我认为这确实让我们产生了一种安全感，即我们的政府在某种程度上在关照我们。鉴于市场现在的表现，如果人们还没有采取任何措施来保护他们的资金，现在把资金转为现金是不是太晚了，或者说太不稳定了，比如说？是的，这是一个很好的问题。而现在把资金转为现金，从历史来看，绝对是你所能做的最糟糕的事情。所以我们的基因决定了我们要做出伟大的举动来生存，你知道，比如捕食者在追赶我们。你知道，那就是战斗、逃跑、僵住的反应。
It's all designed to protect us and save ourselves. So we have these, you know, baked in instincts for survival. And when it comes to financial decisions, however, those instincts are absolutely the wrong thing to do at every possible level. And so the classic mistakes people make in investing is we get really excited. when things are going really well. So picture six months ago, the stock market's at all-time highs. People are, if you're sitting back watching that, you're thinking, oh, no, I'm missing out on this.
这一切都是为了保护我们和拯救我们。所以我们这些内置的生存本能。然而，当涉及到财务决策时，这些本能在每个可能的层面上绝对都是错误的做法。因此，人们在投资中犯的典型错误是，当事情进展得非常顺利时，我们会变得非常兴奋。所以想象一下六个月前，股市处于历史最高点。人们，如果你坐着观看这一切，你会想，哦，不，我错过这个了。
You feel a sense of anxiety. Like, people are making all this money. I'm not making anything. So we have a natural tendency to want to jump on board and buy when things are super expensive. And then when things drop and we lose, our stock loses 30% in value, we have that fear response going the other way. It's sort of like, imagine a herd of wild horses on, you know, on the plane and something scary and they all run. in one direction and then they run back in another direction. This is what happens to human beings in terms of their finances. And so we're wired to do the absolute wrong things, which are buy high
你会感到一种焦虑感。就像，人们都在赚大钱。我什么都没赚。所以我们有一种天然的倾向，想要跟风并在东西超级贵的时候买入。然后当市场下跌我们亏损时，我们的股票损失了30%的价值，我们就会朝着相反的方向产生恐惧反应。这有点像，想象一下平原上的一群野马，你知道，有什么可怕的事情发生，它们都朝着一个方向奔跑，然后又朝着另一个方向奔跑。这就是人类在财务方面发生的事情。所以我们的基因注定要做完全错误的事情，那就是买高
and sell low. And so that instinct to just understand this, don't trust your instincts around money. And if you if you sort of take that to heart, it can really help you out financially. So we should all be buying right now? Well, it depends, right? It sort of depends on what your portfolio looks like. But almost certainly if you look, this is great too. Look back to 2000. And if you look back at charts on what happened in 2008, took a huge hit, bounced around a little bit, and then it was just a steady path right on up. So it really depends on your frame of reference. And one of the problems we have as human beings, and when it comes to investing, it's called a narrow frame of reference. And so, for example, if you pulled up a chart of like the Dow Industrial Average or the S&P 500, these are indexes that track the stock market, if you pulled up a chart that looked at the last month or two,
卖低。因此，理解这种本能，不要盲目信任你关于金钱的直觉。如果你把这一点铭记在心，它真的能在财务上帮到你。所以我们现在都应该买进吗？嗯，这得看情况，对吧？这在某种程度上取决于你的投资组合是什么样的。但几乎可以肯定的是，如果你看一下，这也很好。回看2000年。如果你回看2008年发生的事情的图表，经历了一次暴跌，稍微反弹了一点，然后就是一条稳步向上的路径。所以这真的取决于你的参照框架。作为人类，我们遇到的问题之一，当谈到投资时，这被称为狭隘参照框架。所以，例如，如果你调出一张诸如道琼斯工业平均指数或标普500指数的图表，这些是跟踪股市的指数，如果你调出一张观察过去一两个月的图表，
or three, it's going to look like total catastrophe. You're going to see a bunch of red lines. It looks like our entire life fell off a cliff. So that's called a narrow frame of reference. Now, if you looked at a chart about five, ten years out, or even for fun, look at a hundred-year chart, you're going to see this is actually much more of a pothole when it comes to what's happening in the markets versus a cliff. And so that wider frame of reference really can help settle that your emotional brain, calm it down so you don't do the wrong thing. Isn't this? highly unusual. I mean, I can't think of any other time in history where the markets have done quite what they're doing right now. I mean, even if you look back to the, to the Great Depression,
或者三个月，它看起来就像是一场彻底的灾难。你会看到一堆红线。看起来我们整个人生都从悬崖上跌落了。所以这被称为狭隘的参照框架。现在，如果你看一张五年、十年甚至更有趣的一百年图表，你会发现与市场上正在发生的事情相比，这实际上更像是一个路坑，而不是悬崖。因此，更广泛的参照框架确实可以帮助安定你的情绪大脑，使其平静下来，这样你就不会做错事。这难道不吗？非常不寻常。我的意思是，我想不出历史上还有什么时候市场表现得像现在这样。我的意思是，即使你回看，到大萧条时期，
nobody's working. I mean, we're all sitting at home right now, which is highly unusual. And if we're expecting unemployment to hit 30 percent, let's say, which is one of the projections, do we really have any experience like this? I mean, 2008 may not be the right comparison. Well, actually, you're making a fabulous point, Kim. And the fact is, it's always something new. So back in 2008, and if you can sort of imagine back to 2008, and this is a really helpful exercise, chances are if you were around and paying attention back then, you had some catastrophic thinking going on. It was like there was deep, deep fear that we were experiencing culturally. I'm going to lose all my money. The markets may never recover.
没有人工作。我的意思是，我们现在都坐在家里，这很不寻常。如果我们预计失业率将达到30%，比方说，这是预测之一，我们真的有这样的经历吗？我的意思是，2008年可能不是正确的比较。嗯，事实上，金，你提出了一个极好的观点。事实是，总是有新情况。所以在2008年，如果你能想象一下2008年，这是一个非常有用的练习，如果你当时在场并且在关注，你很可能会有一些灾难化的想法。就像我们在文化上经历着深深的、深深的恐惧。我会失去所有的钱。市场可能永远不会恢复。
This time it's different. This is the same type of thoughts that frankly I have, you know, as I'm drifting off to sleep at night, and my anxiety's kicking in. But it's the exact same catastrophic thinking we had then. It's the exact same catastrophic thinking we had back in 2000. And I really can't go beyond that. But I hear it was the same one we had back in 87 and on and on. So this is built in. It is absolutely totally different. We're not sure. And that's the one thing that's consistent about these economic collapses is that uncertainty and that catastrophic thinking. and those intense emotions of fear. And so I sort of rest with some confidence that, you know, that we are going to manage to get
这次不一样。这与坦率地说，当我在深夜昏昏欲睡时，我的焦虑开始发作时，我脑子里闪过的想法完全是同一类型的想法。但这跟我们在2000年时的灾难性想法完全一样。我真的无法追溯到更早了。但我听说我们在87年也有过同样的经历，诸如此类。所以这是内置的。它绝对是完全不同的。我们不确定。这就是这些经济崩溃唯一一致的地方，那就是不确定性和那种灾难性的想法，以及强烈的恐惧情绪。所以我带着一些信心安定下来，你知道，我们一定会设法度过
through this, just like we have in all the other ones, that this one, it is totally different. For example, like what's totally different? Well, Kim, in the last couple recessions, it was more of a drop-off. I mean, it took months and months or even years to find a bottom where this one might have happened in a matter of a month or two. And again, we're not sure if there's more to go. we're not sure if two or three months from now it's great news and the switch gets turned backed on and everyone's back to work we have no idea and that sort of gets built into our anxiety
这一关，就像我们在所有其他危机中所做的那样，这一次，它是完全不同的。例如，有什么完全不同的地方？嗯，金，在过去的几次衰退中，更像是一个断崖式的下跌。我的意思是，花了几个月甚至几年才找到底部，而这一次可能在一两个月内就发生了。同样，我们不确定是否还有更多要下跌。我们不确定两三个月后是否会是好消息，开关重新打开，每个人都回到工作岗位，我们完全不知道，而这种不确定性就被内化到了我们的焦虑中，
and frankly sets us up to be self-destructive around money. So you've done a lot of research into how people manage their money, the emotions that go into it and the psychological constructs that you've been describing. You've looked at concepts like overconfidence, bias where people have have too narrow a frame of reference, that they don't look at markets over the long term, which is what we're talking about, and anchoring bias. Can you talk about some of these concepts and how they might play into what's happening right now? Sure. Well, I think if you had an overconfidence bias, chances are it's shaken up a little bit, which is probably good for you.
坦率地说，这也让我们在金钱方面走上自我毁灭的道路。所以你对人们如何管理他们的金钱、其中的情绪以及你一直在描述的心理结构做了很多研究。你研究过诸如过度自信、人们具有狭隘参照框架的偏误（他们不从长远角度看市场，这正是我们正在谈论的）以及锚定效应偏误等概念。你能谈谈其中一些概念以及它们可能如何影响当前正在发生的事情吗？当然。嗯，我认为如果你有过度自信的偏误，很有可能会被稍微动摇一下，这可能对你有好处。
And this is sort of our natural tendency to believe that we're much better at things than we actually are. And certainly that was the case in the months preceding this drop. Again, stock markets were going crazy, all sorts of amateur investors, doing lots of trading, having incredible experiences, believing that this related to them, when, you know, statistically you could have a monkey throwing darts at a dartboard and picking winning stocks in the years leading up to this. So that sort of gets baked into the cake around that. And so hopefully, frankly, I want you to be much less confident in what you think you know
这有点像是我们坚信自己比实际情况要好得多的自然倾向。当然，在这场暴跌之前的几个月里确实如此。再次强调，股市当时疯狂上涨，各种各样的业余投资者进行着大量的交易，有着不可思议的经历，并认为这与他们有关，然而（你知道，从统计学上看），在这个危机爆发前的几年里，你完全可以找一只猴子向飞镖盘扔飞镖来挑选获胜的股票。所以这在某种程度上被内置到了这其中。因此，希望，坦率地说，我希望你对你认为自己了解的关于投资和市场的真相的信心大大降低。
to be true about investments and about markets. That's actually really, really healthy for you. They've actually done studies on gender differences here. And it turns out that women are less confident in what is a good stock and where is it going to go. And it turns out that they actually are better at investing as a result. So they actually have better returns by having less confidence and knowing exactly what's going to happen in the future. But we're also starting off with less money and lower wages. So we've got that disadvantage.
这对你来说实际上是非常非常健康的。他们实际上对这里的性别差异做过研究。结果表明，女性对什么是好股票以及它将走向何方缺乏自信。结果证明，因此她们实际上更擅长投资。由于缺乏对未来走向的绝对自信，她们实际上获得了更好的回报。但我们一开始的资金也更少，工资也更低。所以我们有这个劣势。
Absolutely. But you're also better investors. So, and research bears that out. So I think a little bit of a lack of confidence is a really healthy thing when it comes to financial markets. And then, of course, anchoring bias builds in, too. And it creates your anxiety also because the anchor is basically the price at which you think this thing should cost, you know.
绝对是的。但你们也是更好的投资者。所以，研究也证实了这一点。因此，当谈到金融市场时，缺乏一点自信是一件非常健康的事情。然后，当然，锚定效应也会随之产生。它也会制造你的焦虑，因为锚定基本上就是你认为这东西应该花费的价格，你知道。
So you see this with a house you bought. You see this with a stock you bought, you know. If it's like, oh, you bought it at 100, then you could be really stuck on that point. And if it's, if the stock is now working. $75. It's actually not worth $100. This is where that anchoring bias comes in. It's actually now we're $75. And so that's just the reality. And so not being stuck on the past related to that is actually pretty healthy. And you'll notice a pattern here. Flexibility and thinking is really, really helpful when it comes to your relationship with money because times do change, circumstances
所以你在买的房子上看到了这一点。你在买的股票上也看到了这一点，你知道。如果它是，哦，你是以100的价格买的，那么你可能会真的卡在那个点上。如果它是，如果这只股票现在正在运作。75美元。它实际上并不值100美元。这就是锚定效应发挥作用的地方。它现在实际上值75美元。所以这只是现实。因此，不被与之相关的过去所困其实是相当健康的。你会在这里注意到一个规律。思维的灵活性对于你与金钱的关系真的非常非常有帮助，因为时代确实在变，环境
change. And when we're stuck on a rigid belief about how the world works, like for example, my grandfather believing that you can't trust banks with your money. And I get why he got that belief. But when it's rigidly held, that's when it gets us into trouble. Are there exercises that people might be able to go through to help themselves get past some of these constructs, these mental constructs that are not helpful? Yeah, so I'll give you one that I have been using with clients and frankly myself that I used back in 2008 too, and it's really helpful. And it's called the worst case scenario. And so it's sort of an exposure technique. So if you went to see a psychologist because you had a fear of dogs,
也在变。当我们执着于关于世界如何运作的僵化信念时（例如，我爷爷坚信你不能把钱托付给银行），我理解他为什么会有这种信念。但当它被死板地坚持时，这就会给我们带来麻烦。人们是否可以进行一些练习来帮助自己摆脱其中一些没有帮助的建构，这些心理建构？是的，所以我将提供一个我一直与客户合作使用的练习，坦率地说，我自己也在2008年用过，它真的很有帮助。它被称为最坏情况。所以这有点像是一种暴露疗法。因此，如果你因为害怕狗去看心理医生，
you know, your sadistic psychologist would eventually want you to pet a dog. I mean, that would be built into the, into the process. We would want to expose you to that fear. And yes, maybe you got bit by a really nasty dog. So we wouldn't get a nasty dog that we wanted you to pet, but we would want you to imagine petting the dog. We would want you to think about it because we'd want to cure this phobia you have. And so the worst case scenario exercise is sort of built into this too, because your brain is looking at what's happening in the economy as a life or death situation. Okay. It's sort of an on or off switch here in terms of our anxiety.
你知道，你那虐待狂般的心理医生最终会想让你去抚摸一只狗。我的意思是，这会被内置到，到那个过程中。我们希望让你暴露在这种恐惧中。是的，也许你被一只真的很恶劣的狗咬过。所以我们不会找一只恶劣的狗让你去摸，但我们会想让你想象抚摸那只狗。我们会想让你去思考它，因为我们想治愈你拥有的这种恐惧症。因此，最坏情况练习在某种程度上也融入了这一点，因为你的大脑正将经济中正在发生的事情视为生死攸关的情况。好的。就我们的焦虑而言，这有点像是一个开或关的开关。
It's like, everything's fine or, oh, no, I'm going to die. Those are the two, that's where our brain goes. And so chances are if you live in the United States, now chances are that this financial situation is not life-throaming. Now, I say chances are because it could be for you. And so I don't want to diminish that. But for the majority of Americans, when you see unemployment coming in and some of these other supports, chances are it's not life-threatening for you. It's really important to know, though,
这就像，一切都好，或者，哦，不，我要死了。这就是这两种情况，这就是我们大脑走向的地方。如果你住在美国，现在这种财务状况很有可能不是致命的。现在，我说很有可能，因为对你来说它可能是。所以我不想淡化这一点。但对于大多数美国人来说，当你看到失业率上升以及其他一些支持措施时，很有可能这对你来说不是致命的。不过，了解这一点非常重要，
that your financial stress could kill you. And there's been a lot of studies done on this that, that first of all, the American Psychological Association, Stress in America's Survey, consistently has shown since 2007 that money is one of the biggest sources of stress in the lives of Americans, round three out of four. And when times are great, right? This is a stressful thing. Financial stress can kill you. So the worst case scenario exercise is, sort of built into helping you really look at, is this really a life-threatening situation? And so, so basically, you know, it goes like this. So, you know, let's say you're worried about losing your job. So if you lost your job, then what would happen? Well, then I wouldn't
你的财务压力可能会杀死你。对此有很多研究表明，首先，美国心理学会的“美国压力调查”自2007年以来一直显示，金钱是美国人生活中最大的压力来源之一，大约四分之三的人都这么认为。而且是在好时期，对吧？这是一件压力很大的事情。财务压力会杀死你。因此，最坏情况练习旨在帮助你真正审视，这真的是一种生死攸关的情况吗？所以，基本上，你知道，它是这样的。所以，你知道，比方说你担心失业。如果你失业了，那么会发生什么？嗯，然后我就不会
be able to pay my mortgage. Well, if you couldn't pay your mortgage, then what would happen? Well, I might lose my house. Okay, so let's say you lost your house. What would you do then? Well, then I'd have to go live with my parents or my sibling. Okay, so that would be pretty rough, what would that be like? So you see what I'm saying. You just kind of go, keep going down the path. And for many people, what you realize is incredibly uncomfortable, perhaps quite painful, a lot of stress involved, but it's probably not going to kill you. And as a matter of fact, you could probably picture yourself getting back up on your feet, back on your feet, moving forward. And frankly, a lot of people back in 2008 had to do something like that. So they were
能够支付我的房贷。好吧，如果你付不起房贷，那会发生什么？嗯，我可能会失去我的房子。好吧，假设你失去了房子。你接下来会做什么？嗯，那我得去跟我父母或兄弟姐妹住在一起。好吧，那会挺艰难的，那会是什么样？所以你明白我的意思。你只是顺着这条路走下去。对许多人来说，你意识到这极其令人不舒服，也许相当痛苦，涉及很多压力，但它可能不会杀死你。事实上，你大概可以想象自己重新振作起来，重新站起来，继续前进。坦率地说，2008年的很多人不得不做类似的事情。所以他们
hit really hard. They lost a house. They had to do that. And it took them a few years to recover. But anyway, useful exercise to sort of expose you to some of that thinking and those fears and really sort of evaluate your catastrophic thinking whether or not it's true. A lot of us are defined by our jobs and also by the amount of money that we have or that we're earning. And this gives us a sense of identity, a feeling of security and purpose in life. So as people lose their jobs or lose their livelihood, what is going to happen to them psychologically? Yes. And so great question. You know, retirement sounds like a great idea, right?
受到了沉重打击。他们失去了房子。他们不得不这样做。他们花了几年时间才恢复过来。无论如何，这是一个有用的练习，可以让你暴露在一些那样的思考和恐惧中，并真正评估你的灾难性想法，看看它是否属实。我们许多人都是由我们的工作以及我们拥有的金钱数量或我们赚取的金钱来定义的。这给我们带来了身份认同感、安全感以及生活的目标感。因此，当人们失去工作或生计时，他们的心理将会发生什么？是的。所以这是一个很好的问题。你知道，退休听起来是个不错的主意，对吧？
For many people who actually end up doing it, it can become a mental health crisis. And it's getting to some of what you're asking there. It's like depending on the degree to which your self-esteem and your self-worth is built into your job or your role, for example. You know, when that is gone, it creates a crisis for many people. Like, how do I get this need to feel productive, this need to feel like I'm doing something good in the world? my social needs met, my connections met. And, you know, this is a challenging time because many of us are losing our ability to engage, well, you know, socially.
对许多最终这样做的人来说，它可能会演变成一场心理健康危机。这触及了你刚才所问的一部分。这就像取决于你的自尊和自我价值感建立在你的工作或角色上的程度，例如。你知道，当这些不复存在时，它会给许多人带来危机。比如，我如何满足这种感到自己有生产力的需求，这种觉得自己在这个世界上做了一些好事的需求？我的社交需求得到了满足，我的联系得到了满足。而且，你知道，这是一个充满挑战的时期，因为我们许多人正在失去参与的能力，好吧，你知道，在社交上。
Like, we're actually being told not to socialize. And that's something that makes this crisis very different too, because typically psychologists would be telling you in moments like this, you need to get together with people you love. You need to spend time with people. Don't socially easily. Literally, we tell people don't socially icily. And yet we're being told we need to do this. Like, this is something we need to do.
就像，我们实际上被告知不要社交。这也是让这场危机变得非常不同的地方，因为通常心理学家在这样的时刻会告诉你，你需要和你爱的人聚在一起。你需要花时间与人相处。不要轻易进行社交隔离。字面意思上，我们告诉人们不要社交隔离。然而我们却被告知我们需要这样做。就像，这是我们需要做的事情。
And so, again, a crisis, I also do think there's an opportunity built in here, too. So you're going to be stuck at home, perhaps stuck at home with people that you love, you know. And so for me, on a very personal level, I've been putting more time into, you know, how am I evaluating myself as a husband with my wife and as a father? And I've just been paying more attention to those roles. And frankly, I'm a better father now than I was two months ago because I'm starting to see my kids in a different way. And, you know, just for example, my son the other day was like, hey, can I help with the dishes? He's seven.
所以，再次强调，这是一个危机，我也认为其中蕴含着一个机遇。所以你要被困在家中，也许要和你爱的人一起被困在家中，你知道。所以对我来说，在非常个人的层面上，我投入了更多的时间来思考，你知道，我如何作为一名丈夫与我的妻子以及作为一名父亲来评估自己？我只是更多地关注了这些角色。坦率地说，我现在是一个比两个月前更好的父亲，因为我开始以不同的方式看待我的孩子们。而且，你知道，举个例子，我儿子有一天说，嘿，我可以帮忙洗碗吗？他七岁。
And I realized in the past, I'd been like, no, buddy, don't worry about it. You do that. I'll just finish this up. Now I'm like, whoa, this is an opportunity for me to connect with him and mentor him and teach him something. And so frankly, I've been really focused more on, you know, how can I be a better husband, a better father and build up those roles, which are really, really important to me. And frankly, when, you know, when I'm at the office working really hard, those roles aren't getting as much attention. So there are opportunities built in here. So you sound, for the most part, pretty optimistic through it all.
我意识到在过去，我会说，不，伙计，别担心这个。你做那个吧。我来把这个收尾。现在我说，哇，这是一个与他建立联系、指导他并教给他一些东西的机会。所以坦率地说，我真的把更多精力放在，你知道，我如何能成为一个更好的丈夫、更好的父亲，并建立起那些对我来说非常非常重要的角色上。坦率地说，当，你知道，当我在办公室拼命工作时，那些角色并没有得到那么多的关注。所以这里面内置着机遇。所以你听起来，在很大程度上，经历这一切时还是相当乐观的。
I guess you've got some good endorphins going up there in the brain that you're able to carry on and not focus on the negative. But I'm hearing that that's pretty much the bottom line of what it is that you are advising people right now to look on the bright side, to hang on and not to lose hope through all this. Is that an accurate summary? I would say so. But I'm also not trying to diminish the fear and the anxiety. And I've actually spoken about my own. own fear and anxiety. And it's going to emerge and it's going to happen. It's absolutely going to happen. And if you don't have some of that, you're sort of in denial about what's happening, you know,
我想你的大脑里产生了一些好的内啡肽，使你能够坚持下去，而不专注于负面情绪。但我听说这几乎就是你现在建议人们的核心要点：向前看，坚持下去，不要在这一切中失去希望。这是一个准确的总结吗？我会这么说。但我也没有试图淡化恐惧和焦虑。我实际上谈到过我自己的。自己的恐惧和焦虑。它会出现，而且一定会发生。它绝对会发生。如果你没有其中一些情绪，你就是在否认正在发生的事情，你知道，
but I don't, but I don't feel like there's a ton of value in lingering there. I mean, stay there as long as you need to, um, to process, for example, loss. Like you've lost some income. Maybe that income has led to you having to, um, not enjoy some of the things you're able to enjoy or, you know, many people literally have lost vacations, you know, or they've lost their ability to produce. These are very, very real things. And so I, I think that grieving those is really important and thinking about a plan for after this, super important. Do that worst case scenario exercise, dive into the pain of everything bad that can happen.
但我并不觉得停留在那里有什么太大的价值。我的意思是，只要你需要，就在那里呆多久，以便处理，例如，损失。就像你失去了一些收入。也许那收入导致你不得不，无法享受你曾经能够享受的一些东西，或者，你知道，许多人字面上失去了假期，你知道，或者他们失去了生产能力。这些都是非常非常真实的事情。所以我觉得，哀悼这些是非常重要的，并且要想出一个之后的计划，超级重要。做那个最坏情况练习，深入体验可能发生的所有糟糕事情的痛苦之中。
But I also feel like there are other things happening right now. And what you pay attention to gets bigger. And so if you're staying in that too long, frankly, it becomes dysfunctional and not very helpful. And so I believe that there are two sides of reality here. And one is very painful. and the other is there's tons of opportunities. So I don't think it's rose-colored glasses, but I do think it's important to look for those opportunities.
但我也觉得现在还有其他事情在发生。你关注什么，什么就会变大。所以如果你在那种状态停留太久，坦率地说，它就会变得失调且毫无帮助。因此，我认为这里现实有两个方面。一方面是非常痛苦的。而另一方面则有大量的机遇。所以我不认为这是玫瑰色的眼镜，但我确实认为寻找这些机遇很重要。
I mean, you probably have some time at home. I mean, I think it's a useful exercise. For people who feel like they need professional help, particularly around money, anxiety, are there special places where they should go or there are particular types of psychologists who are better at helping than others? Well, I think that psychologists back in 2008, and this is anecdotal, But they, I think maybe even for the first time as a profession, we really started to take seriously this whole idea of financial anxiety and people struggling with money, frankly because most of our clients were struggling with that. So that was being brought into the therapy room.
我的意思是，你可能在家有些时间。我的意思是，我认为这是一个有用的练习。对于那些觉得自己需要专业帮助的人，特别是围绕金钱焦虑的人，是否有他们应该去的特殊地方，或者是否有某些特定类型的心理学家比其他人更能提供帮助？嗯，我认为2008年的心理学家，这只是个人经验，但是他们，我认为可能甚至作为一种职业，第一次真正认真对待了这种关于财务焦虑和人们挣扎于金钱的整个概念，坦率地说，因为我们大多数客户都在为此挣扎。所以这被带入了治疗室。
And so I think psychologists are actually extremely well equipped to help people with anxiety. And most of the decisions we make around money or most of the things we need to do around money, we kind of already know what we need to do. So like, for example, most of most Americans have problems with money because we're spending too much and we're not saving enough. And I've yet to find it somebody who doesn't know they shouldn't do that. So I think a lot of our struggles in finances aren't technical. So it's not like you actually need a psychologist to tell you which stock to buy. That's, that's not what a psychologist would do. And that's really not your issue.
因此，我认为心理学家实际上具备极其出色的能力来帮助人们应对焦虑。我们在金钱方面做出的大多数决策，或者我们在金钱方面需要做的大多数事情，其实我们已经知道我们需要做什么了。所以，例如，大多数美国人对金钱有问题，是因为我们花得太多而存得不够。而且我还没遇到过谁不知道他不应该那样做。所以我认为我们在财务上的许多挣扎并不是技术性的。所以这并不意味着你真的需要一个心理学家来告诉你买哪只股票。那，那不是心理学家会做的事，那也真的不是你的问题。
And I think psychologists are really well equipped to help people deal with the anxiety. And the other opportunity that's happening here too is more and more telehealth opportunities are being. presented. And so that's something that I hope lingers at the end of this is, you know, people are doing more online therapy, phone therapy, and that kind of thing. So there's an opportunity, perhaps, for people who weren't really engaged in therapy before, to be engaged in it now as a result. Yeah, that's definitely becoming much more available. And we at APA had been working hard to make that more available to people. Well, Dr. Clance, you've been extremely helpful. I really appreciate your joining with us today. If you have any final advice or words you'd like to
而且我认为心理学家确实具备很好的能力来帮助人们应对焦虑。这里正在发生的另一个机遇是，越来越多的远程医疗机会正在被呈现出来。所以这就是我希望在这结束时能够延续下去的东西，你知道，人们正在做更多的在线治疗、电话治疗以及诸如此类的事情。所以这可能是一个机会，对于那些以前没有真正参与治疗的人来说，因此现在可以参与其中。是的，这肯定变得越来越容易获得了。我们美国心理学会也一直在努力让人们更容易获得这些服务。嗯，克兰茨博士，你真的帮了很大的忙。我非常感谢你今天加入我们。如果你有任何最后的建议或想说的话，
part, please do. Well, I mean, I think it's really important to know that you're not alone. You're certainly not alone. And we're all going through this together and we're all going to get through this together. Humanity has been faced with this type of thing. Every time you take your kid in to get shots when they're a baby, each one of those shots represents a pandemic that has happened like this that has had a profound effect on humanity. So we've dealt with this over time. We're going to get on the other side of this. And so think about on the other side of this, looking back to who you are right now and what you're doing right now. And just try to build into there.
请说吧。嗯，我的意思是，我认为了解自己并不孤单真的非常重要。你当然不孤单。我们都在共同经历这一切，我们也都会共同度过这一切。人类一直面临着这种类型的事情。每次你带你的孩子去打疫苗时，当他们还是婴儿的时候，每一次疫苗都代表着曾发生过这样的流行病，这对人类产生了深远的影响。所以随着时间的推移，我们已经应对了这些。我们会走过这一关。所以想想这一关的另一边，回过头来看看此时此刻的你以及你现在正在做的事。试着把这些融入其中。
How would you feel really good about how you went through this? And of course, you're going to have bumps in the road. You're going to be stressed. You're going to have down days, absolutely. And then the second thing I would say is, yes, we need to socially isolate, but don't actually do that. I mean, there are other ways to connect with people. And so, you know, whether it's FaceTime or Skype or phone calls, find ways to connect
对于你如何度过这段经历，你会感到真的很欣慰吗？当然，路上会有磕磕绊绊。你会感到压力。你会有情绪低落的日子，绝对会有。然后我要说的第二件事是，是的，我们需要进行社交隔离，但不要真的完全与世隔绝。我的意思是，还有其他方式可以与人联系。所以，你知道，无论是FaceTime、Skype还是电话，找到方法去与
with people that you love. People, we need to do this. This is something very important to us. So make an effort to do that. Great. Well, thank you again. Dr. Brad Clontz. My pleasure.
你爱的人联系。人们，我们需要这样做。这对我们来说是非常重要的事情。所以要努力做到这一点。太好了。好的，再次谢谢你。布拉格·克兰茨博士。我的荣幸。
So for our listeners, if you have any comments or ideas you'd like to share about our podcast, send an email to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website and download all episodes at www. www. speakingof psychology.org. Thank you again for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以对于我们的听众，如果您有任何想分享的关于我们播客的评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。也就是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连写，在 APA.org。您可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何您获取播客的地方找到“心理学对话”的往期节目。您也可以访问我们的网站并下载所有节目，网址是 www.speakingofpsychology.org。再次感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。